nearly a year ago league of legends
content creator hashin
shin was permanently banned from twitch
after being accused of grooming
multiple underage girls he denied it
called those accusations fake and
started a dispute with
voy another league content creator
that's lasted
until this day and now hashin shin has
asked to be unbanned from twitch which
has set off a fresh round of controversy
and resurfaced these serious allegations
[Music]
this story begins way back in july of
2020 so
why are we talking about it right now
well back on july 6th
of this year hashin shin in a now
unlisted video
essentially pleaded his case with twitch
he said that he should be allowed back
on the platform and that his ban from
july of 2020
was unjustified hello everybody and for
the first time i'm asking for an unban
from twitch
during my drama there were large
misunderstandings from everyone as to
what happened which only got worse as
people continued to exaggerate the drama
from there one of the women who
originally accused him of grooming her
quote tweeted him and said quote your ex
didn't get you banned you got yourself
banned by using the platform to prey on
me
end quote from there league of legends
content creator voy boy published an
hour-long video breaking down the
allegations from
10 plus women who've accused shinshin of
grooming them
and of sexual misconduct for each set of
allegations voyboy showed screenshots of
messages that appeared to be from hashin
shin
who is in his 30s at the time these
messages allegedly were of a
sexually explicit nature sent to girls
as young as 15.
this is the reason he got banned on
twitch not because i made a video asking
people to stand up with victims
not because people talked about on
twitter because twitch verified
that he was using the platform to prey
on underage girls so
that is settled there's no debate about
that hashing shin has since responded
twice to voy boy's hour-long video he
called him out
once again denied the allegations and
stated that he's moving on
from this entire situation okay so
that's the most recent news
now let's step back and try to
understand how we got to this point
this story really began in july of 2020
when accusations started cropping up on
twitter
that hashin shin was grooming girls as
young as 15.
on july 14th of 2020 hashin shin
published a
37-page google doc outright denying
all of those accusations he stated that
the screenshotted messages brought
forward by multiple women were faked and
that this whole
scenario was his ex-girlfriend ally's
attempt
to ruin him in that google doc shinshin
stated that his relationship with ali
was toxic
that she gaslet him throughout their
time together and that at one point
ali allegedly quote extorted him
for money the rest of the document is
shinshin going
through and refuting each set of
allegations
he also accused ali of colluding with
these women
and of faking the twitter discord and
other messages that were used as
evidence against him
a day later on july 15th youtuber dai
published a video breaking down all of
those accusations
and shared the perspectives of five
different women who accused to shin chin
of sexual misconduct on top of the
sexually explicit messages shinshin
allegedly asked for
and sent nudes to these women he was
also accused of sending videos of
himself
masturbating dye's video also included a
google doc
which housed all of the screenshotted
messages that were referenced
in the video one of the screenshots
provided by a woman named vicky who
accused
shinshin of sexual misconduct appeared
to show him admitting to her
that he had sent inappropriate messages
to a minor before
according to dye's google document vicky
was 16 at the time that hashin shin
started sending her these messages
dye's document also included multiple
links to audio logs of what sounds to be
hashin shin
saying sexually explicit things in
multiple different calls
to the women that we've just talked
about then two days later on july 17th
two more women who go by kalty and vicky
on twitter
published statements about their
experiences with hashin
here's an excerpt from kalti's statement
quote if anyone else has similar
experiences to this because i know there
are many
i encourage you to speak up now he's
been doing this for years with little to
no consequences
he's been denying all previous
allegations with the argument they are
fake i am here to disprove that end
quote
and here's an excerpt from vicki's
statement quote these conversations did
not go far
as i had a boyfriend at the time and
quickly blocked him once the
conversation escalated to become
suspicious
and creepy had i not set this boundary
i'm sure the conversation would have
escalated similarly
to kalti's story end quote that same day
the 17th
hashin shin published a video once again
denying all of the allegations
he also stated that the messages being
used as evidence against him
were doctored and fake he described the
youtuber dai
as quote a looney tunes character who
knowingly posted false information
about him then on top of that hashin
chin apologized to anyone that he had
been
quote weird or creepy towards but
maintained that he didn't groom
anyone or do anything illegal with the
women involved
he also restated this apology and two
now deleted
posts then on july 21st of 2020 voyboy
published a
video titled standing with victims where
he discussed the situation
at large and stated that the victims
should be heard
and listened to he also accused shinshin
of trying to manipulate this situation
to his advantage
and of turning his audience against
those who were hurt
this included getting his audience to
review bomb voy boy's video
and to continually harass him in the
comments and
because of that voy boy turned the
comments off
on that video now a day later on july
22nd
2020 hashin shin was permanently banned
from twitch
based on the statement and messages that
kalti
came forward with this wasn't a
short-term ban either this was a
permanent ban from the platform one that
has remained
in place to this day now skipping ahead
a bit on the timeline here
in october of 2020 hashin published a
video
stating that the fbi had investigated
him but he had not been arrested
or charged with anything in that video
again he stated that all of the evidence
against him was
fake now to be clear we haven't been
able to confirm that an fbi
investigation took place
and that he was cleared of anything from
there things died down for a while
although hashin shin periodically
maintained his innocence online and
continued to harass voyboy that brings
us back around to now
when on july 6th of this year hashin
shin published that video
asking to be unbanned on twitch there is
an element of revisionist history here
with hashin shin trying to chalk up this
whole thing to a dispute with an
ex-girlfriend
and really just downplaying the severity
of this whole situation
and again that july 6 video from hashin
shin sparked the quote tweet from
kalti and it sparked the league scene
backlash it also led to the hour-long
video from
voyboy going over messages from the now
10 plus women who have come forward
since those original allegations were
levied
at this point that's about it hashin
shin is still banned on twitch
he's still beefing with voyboy and the
two sides
shinshin's audience and everyone else
remain
at odds over how to feel about
everything that's
[Music]
happened
you